[Musique]
moi j'ai bien
dormi directement ouais non mais j'ai
peut-être trop bu je pense que j'ai
abusé peut-être de champagne si je passe
du coup on n'a rien fait quoi ya pas eu
de 15 noms certains noms sont apparus
timorés vendu voici tu dormais bah oui
mais tu aurais pu me réveiller
il donnait un coup l'ambiance ont quand
même on voit pas on voit pas les
[Musique]
robinets dans le 13me dans
une guerre c'est quoi
au complet quoique en gros - food il ya
des gros bras hier certains ont boycotté
pour les emplois et le chat botté ipa
jouer qu'un seul but avec casino
on a le cerveau
serviette dans la tête dans le crâne
purée ça vous du bas cerveau entérique
ah bah oui le loup dans quasiment toutes
tes tripes
autant de connexions nerveuses fontan de
neurones là-bas en bas qu'en haut
pratiquement 200 10 ans 100 millions 200
millions d'imagés alors on sait
désormais qu'une conversation secrète
oui c'est installer s'installe entre nos
deux cerveaux nom se dit par l'entremise
excuse moi le mexicain se sera pas
possible aujourd'hui
un nouveau sponsor nous a rejoint
peut-être peut-on récupère cette
nouvelle publicité dont nous sommes très
fiers lorsque vous souffrez de dire et
c'est probablement le signe que votre
microbiote intestinal et fragilisées ou
que vous avez mangé restaurants
d'entreprises bat à tous les deux tout
ce qu'il faut pour cuisiner absolument
ouais je n'utilise que des produits du
terroir
des terroirs
hier j'ai pondu que joeystarr c'est vrai
je vais l'aider un petit peu il lance
son magazine de cuisine alors ça et
voilà qu'il a hésité à appeler laisse
pas traîner ton fish'n'chips
oui attendez vous avez les jeux de mots
il y aura la recette de la bouillabaisse
besseberg perçu non moi j'ai pas trop
dormi pas du tout même
[Musique]
endroit voici l pourquoi qui ressort un
peu non tant pis bon apparemment il ya
pas que ça hein
ça découvert un truc à des surprises
et des gaz la nuit
le coach entrant en coin dans le peten
il faut de pâques en fête s'y croisent
un cochon payé nous croire je suis un
mec il n'y pas mais est-ce qu après ce
repas en fera pas le concert
si ces défauts comme tu dis
la scène s'est déroulée lundi dernier
lors du dîner organisé à laquelle ring
grosse galerie en présence de boris
johnson du prince charles et de camilla
et de joe biden au cours d'une
discussion entre le président américain
et la duchesse de cornouailles camilla
aurais je cite entendu un pet l'on est
bruyant impossible à ignorer fin de
citation c'est dans le daily mail c'est
dans les journaux dans la sous- partout
du daily mail confie que depuis camilla
n'arrête pas d'en parler john libre
si un cochon qui gronde en son piteux
moi je vous dis c'est quelque chose qui
va nous faire péter bassett pois chiches
chinois mangent tout un serais je pas
tendres mais voyez par vous et merci
pour ces douces confidences félicien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'imagine que vous connaissez déjà les
batailles de boules de neige peut-être
vous en avez fait vous avez participé au
raid que vous connaissez mon les
batailles de boules de neige
vont passer très sérieux ça se passe en
inde tous les ans les habitants d'un
village s'adonnent à ce rituel
traditionnel la vache on sait la borne
hand est un animal qui est sacré et se
recouvrir de ses excréments aurait des
vertus qui permettrait d'éviter de
tomber malade toutes les études qui
sortent en ce moment montrent que les
gens sont très bien protégées avec les
vaccins qu'on a qu'on a à disposition et
dans le temps donc effectivement des
vagues épidémiques n'ont aucun rapport
entre cette année l'année dernière c'est
donc ça qu'il faut pas avoir la même
émotion quand on regarde les chiffres
cette année par rapport à l'année
dernière que ce soit en france ou en
allemagne d'ailleurs rythme et vous
répondez pas m'agace j'ai rien compris
parce que j'ai pas compris votre
question évoquée mais alors ça vous êtes
très bas alors moi vous apprenez à nous
laver l'ajout net oui mais c'est là
j'étais sans que ça allez vous faire
rire mais en fait c'est un sujet
extrêmement sérieux et très utile parce
qu'on a beaucoup de d'infection qui sont
liées à des
toilettes inadéquate face à peu près
d'oshawa s'en alla roi tu veux toujours
en moi bien sûr ah bon ça ne dérange pas
bon bah ça va alors ça fait partie du
paquet
je suis prêt début de la découverte je
confirme
[Musique]
c'est génial toi bah oui j'ai toujours
envie d'elle automatiquement bah oui bah
ouais non il est courageux quand même là
le pauvre il a du mérite pour le coup le
vagin ce n'était pas pas mais le gland
doit absolument se nettoyer et vous
l'avez tous constaté que des fois même
les prépuce sont des réservoirs à des
substances un peu et ça peut créer des
infections lefa bouffer par contre
d'accord voilà qu'il est très important
pour les hommes d'utiliser pareil un gel
intime ou de se laver à l'eau claire en
tout cas une fois par jour j'achète et
ce en direct sur france 2 si on m'avait
dit ça un jour que je dirais ça jeff et
il y en a quand il ya des gens qui
disent que c'est un peu cru que ce que
vous leur répondez à 0 k
allez on la reprend qui disent que c'est
un petit peu le monsieur si je peux si
je peux me permettre oui c'était une
blague à monsieur oui de la pole day a
paru être déjà vu maintenant le plus
c'est un mec qui pourrait te plaît
mouvement oui oui
mais quoi mais tient toujours est menée
aux séries 3 intelligent pour moi mais
pourquoi être fois qu'on patine pas je
comprends pas tout ce qu'il me dit
apprécier le moment où est ce que b je
me sens plus débile que ce que je le
suis déjà c'est un peu compliqué t
changé et d'avoir une discussion avec
jonathan il a vraiment un cuit sous des
mesures et le bronze sonne moins creuse
que ça sonne moins creux oui larmes on
sent que le voyez c'est vide à
l'intérieur pour aller dans cette lettre
avec lescure olivier en 10 secondes vous
avez proposé recul
gad alors moi je suis humoriste un jeu
pas là pour faire donc j'ai trouvé
ça marche presque ça marche pas de trop
mais je suis là pour faire rire